event venues are reopening across the
valley people are feeling a little more
comfortable attending public gatherings
but as restrictions ease the rape crisis
center is warning people to party smart
bianca holman is live now with more
about sexual assault awareness month
good morning bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
we all know the las vegas strip
is a prime place for people to gather
and celebrate
and with more opportunities to come
together now the rape crisis center
wants folks to keep
safety at the top of mind matter of fact
april is sexual assault awareness month
so the rape crisis center and lvmpd
want folks to party smart so it's been
about a year since people were able to
gather and celebrate so there's a lot of
excitement right now to get together
but predators are using these reopening
settings to do harm
so advocates want people to keep their
guard up the executive director of the
rape crisis center tells us
calls from hospitals for those who are
going for sexual assault exams
that number is ticking back up already
ours is a very simple message
arrive together stick together leave
together if people
are able to do that it's not going to
avoid
every potentially you um dangerous
situation
but it's certainly going to go a long
way in making sure that
folks at least know their group of
friends is
is going to have a great evening out and
return home
safely and together so here are some
helpful
tips and information the rape crisis
center has a 24-hour hotline you can see
the number here listed on your screen
and if you're housed with your abuser
there's a text message line and that is
the second number listed there
and they even have an online chat
available on their website
rcclv.org so take note of that
information if you
are somebody in danger right now and
then also coming up in the six o'clock
hour i'm going to share some tips
from the rape crisis center that they
want everyone to keep it top of mind
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now